[Musique]
sur les 270 nécessaires à la victoire
pour l'instant donald trump a gagné 2
sont treize grands électeurs joe biden
les sept états encore incertain
représente 86 grands électeurs rien
n'est donc encore joué
les américains vont devoir encore
patienter mais comme je le dis depuis le
début ce n'est pas à moi ni à donner un
train de déclarer le vainqueur de cette
élection c'est au peuple américain mais
je reste optimiste quant aux résultats
donald trump a immédiatement réagi sur
twitter accusant les démocrates de
vouloir voler l'élection
un message que twitter a choisi de
masquer avec un message d'avertissement
qui vous prévient que ce switch site est
susceptible d'être trompé c'est fou la
réélection de dalton est meilleur pour
la france pourquoi parce que donald
trump c'est le retour des nations c'est
l'arrêt de cette mondialisation sauvage
de cette dérégulation ce qui va se
passer je pense instyle dans les états
comme la pennsylvanie le michigan où le
risque on sait comme seront pas capables
de compter tous les bulletins de vote
raciste ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'à 22h
le soir de l'élection
tron va dire merci à vous les américains
de m'avoir élu c'est terminé bonne
journée
on a gagné en caroline du nord soixante
seize mille voix d'avancé avec presque
aucune voix qui restent à compter et
tout à coup tout s'arrête
c'est de la fraude avec victime le
peuple américain
c'est une honte pour ce pays on se
préparer à gagner cette élection
et honnêtement on a gagné en particulier
ceux parieurs britanniques qui a misé 5
millions de dollars sur la victoire de
trump on l'a appris hier son identité
est tenue secrète mais selon la presse
anglaise il s'agit d'un ancien banquier
qui auraient eu des contacts avec le
plan trump avant de faire ce pari fou et
les jours suivants tous ces votes par
correspondance ont été comptabilisés on
verra que toyota il donne à remporter
ses états mais à ce moment entre hommes
va ni roi je revoyais seul avait dit que
c'était trop tôt
vous avez dit que ces barbares n'aurait
cependant qu iron la cour suprême des
etats unis nous souhaitons que les votes
soient arrêtés on ne veut pas qu'il
retrouve des bulletins de vote à 4
heures du matin les résultats officiels
ne devraient pas être connus avant
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
notre hôpital va continuer à être soumis
à rude épreuve à une plus rude épreuve
encore dans les jours à venir
la réalité hospitalière est plus
préoccupante aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était en mars dernier le pire c'est
que nous ne puissions pu accueillir tous
les patients qui arrivent ça voudrait
dire quoi ça voudrait dire qu'on va
installer des tentes devant les hôpitaux
et qu'on va être obligé de choisir quels
sont les patients qu'on va pouvoir
prendre en charge est ce qu'on va
laisser mourir
coup de théâtre à l'assemblée nationale
il est 21h 45 hier soir l'opposition
parlementaire emmenée par les
républicains profit des rangs clairsemés
dans la majorité pour réduire la durée
de l'état d'urgence il est adopté
un camouflet pour le gouvernement ils
étaient tous les deux en visite dans le
centre hospitalier de corbeil essonnes
au début l'ambiance était bon enfant
mais très vite on va aller voir à côté
de malades en réanimation
ces images de sont utiles donc on
voulait montre la réalité
c'est pour les malentendants certains
lycées elle est là la réalité de
capitaux
elle est là la réalité des hôpitaux
c'est ça la réalité nos hôpitaux
vous êtes en train de débattre de ce
sujet alors que nous soyons se bat pour
forer dépit de cette manière-là à
d'autres hôpitaux
il faut qu'on limite au maximum nos
contacts au strict minimum c'est-à-dire
la cellule familiale respecte plus le
confinement qu'on respecte plus le
confinement
oui mais ça mais la position dans un
hémicycle
et oui nous avons le droit et nous
allons continuer de critiquer vos
décisions parce que la démocratie c'est
la frontière comme cela que ça vous
plaise ou non